трибунал потрібен цьому світові як кров
змусити Путіна предстати перед цим
трибуналом фізично ну це майже
нереалістична задача ми фактично робимо
світовий президент такого в історії не
було вони будуть ізольовані від всього
світу разом назавжди багато корисних і
некорисних ідіотів зрадників вони нікуди
не поділися вони рано чи пізно піднімуть
голову і з цього треба теж робити
висновок
Пане Андрію Ви працюєте над притягненням
Росії до відповідальності за воєнні
злочини йдеться про міжнародний трибунал
Я хочу почати з гори Скажіть будь ласка
наскільки
реалістична є та перспектива що
Володимир Путін сяде на лаву підсудних
перспектива притягнення Володимира
Путіна до відповідальності є
реалістичною з усіх точок зору і з
кримінально-правової і цивілізаційною і
з інших трибунал
потрібен цьому світові як кров тому що
ми з вами маємо справу з самим великим
воєнним конфліктом з часів Другої
світової війни в Європі що людство не
дасть юридичну оцінку
конкретним особам які розв'язали цю
неоголошену війну
на річці можна буде ставити крапку
йдеться про окремий спеціальний трибунал
чому саме окремий трибунал потрібен у
цьому випадку це дуже просто тому що
міжнародний кримінальний суд Він має
свою юрисдикцію і він дійсно окрім
воєнних злочинів розслідування злочинів
геноциду злочинів проти людяності він
може розслідувати злочин агресії але
Питання в тому що Ані Україна Ані
україна-агресор вони не ратифікували
Римський статут і фактично
МКС він не зможе дати юридичну оцінку
злочину агресії злочин агресії є
похідним злочином він вважається в
міжнародному праві матір'ю всіх злочинів
і саме з
метою доведення виник конкретних осіб у
цьому злочині Ми наполягаємо на
започаткуванні окремого трибуналу який
би міг бути створений на підставі
міжнародного договору між Україною і
іншими країнами
і юрисдикція якого не перетинаючись з
юрисдикцією міжнародного кримінального
суду
вона би полягала виключно в доведені
вини в злочинів вчинення злочину агресії
наскільки складно довести ось цей злочин
агресії практичної точки зору злочин
агресії доводиться не складно злочин
агресії для глядачів поясню це
використання незаконне використання
збройних сил однієї країни проти
Незалежності
територіальної цілісності і суверенітету
іншої держави
ми розуміємо що всі публічні заяви
очільника країни агресора вони
задокументовані починаючи від виступу
про так звану спеціальну воєнного
операцію що є дефектом розв'язанням
війни агресивної війни проти іншої
незалежної держави публічні виступи
військового командування країни-агресора
Саме ці докази вони є ключовими в
доведенні
вчинення злочину агресії проти України
але тут ви говорите що для того щоб
створити цей окремий міжнародний
трибунал потрібно підписати міжнародний
договір відповідно там країни різні
зможуть надсилати і своїх прокурорів або
вони просто визнаватимуть юрисдикцію
визнаватимуть рішення Ось цього
трибуналу правильно ми сьогодні говоримо
про те що ключовим треком для
започаткування роботи цього трибуналу є
дійсно міжнародний договір ми
розглядаємо кілька сценаріїв як його
підписувати є сценарії Коли Україна
підпише міжнародний договір з конкретним
з конкретними країнами
і Цей договір залишатиметься відкритим
для його підписання і ратифікацією в
майбутньому для того щоб рішення цього
трибуналу воно мало юридичну силу і
розповсюджувалися на юрисдикції окремих
країн і друге сценарій за яким Україна
а-а може підписати цей міжнародний
договір наприклад з Європейським Союзом
який уніфіковано виступає від імені
Європейського Союзу для того щоб і
зекономити час і відразу
розширити юрисдикцію рішень цього треба
мало на цивілізовану Європу чи є єдність
серед європейських він в Європейському
Союзі готовність підписати такий договір
переважна єдність є я дійсно вимушений
визнати що є окремі країни скептики Я
думаю що всі про ці країни знають Це
Німеччина - це Франція тому що в
започаткуванні цього трибуналу вони
бачать більше символізму аніж конкретної
практичної притягнення до
відповідальності Путіна Це не зовсім так
тому що ми очевидно розуміємо що змусити
Путіна
предстати перед цим трибуналом фізично
ну це майже нереалістична задача Але я
вважаю що якщо
внаслідок
юридично визнання злочинцем цих людей за
розв'язання злочину агресії географія
міжнародних подорожей Путіна і його
воєнного командування звузиться
наприклад до відвідування серії або
Північної Кореї
ефект від діяльності від роботи цього
трибуналу вже буде досягнутий це буде
означати що в будь якій цивілізованій
країні яка визнає рішення цього
трибуналу яке підписала міжнародний
договір або долучилося пізніше до
підписання цього договору і ратифікували
в себе що ці люди вони не будуть
почуватися безпечно у всьому
цивілізованому світі зараз головне для
нас
це перший такий перший етап перший
рівень - це максимально
широко розповсюдити юрисдикцію цього
требуналу на всю Європу залучити до
цього процесу Сполучені Штати Америки
Великобританію Канаду я думаю що якщо от
саме в такій ми ми цей етап пройдемо то
далі воно буде вже напів в
напівавтоматичному режимі цивілізований
світ він буде долучатися до цієї історії
часові рамки коли може бути створений
це коли може початися якась практична
робота
досліджували питання створення по
часовим рамкам різних трибуналів
розуміємо що це зазвичай відбувалося
дуже довго але певні події в нас
вселяють певний оптимізм обережний
оптимізм як то Наприклад ми за ці майже
півроку війни встигли отримати кілька
важливих надважливих політичних рішень
наприклад кілька резолюції
парламентської асамблеї Ради Європи яка
підтримує де створення цього трибуналу
Ми отримали Рішення Європейського
парламенту з закликом про створення
цього треба трибуналу і з наданням йому
технічної фінансової допомоги ми станом
на сьогодні проводимо вже практичні
переговори з окремими європейськими
країнами
в юрисдикції яких цей трибунал може
розпочати свою роботу і фактично буде
розташований і саме керуючись оцим
обережним оптимізмом У нас є план до
кінця цього року вийти на затвердження
вже внаслідок обговорення дискусії з
нашими партнерами зарубіжними вийти на
обговорення вже працюючи моделі цього
трибуналу для того щоб можна було швидко
розвернути Fill до офіс тобто базовий
офіс з прокурорів які розпочнуть
підготовчі оцю підготовчу стадію для
започаткування цього треба трибуналу в
конкретній країні
У мене є У нас є амбітна ціль для того
щоб це треба нас запрацював в наступному
році без відносно там пори року чи
місяця ми хочемо щоб це було якомога
швидше
Росія анексувала Крим 14-му році
створила псевдореспубліки на Донбасі
після цього 24 лютого вона розпочала
нове повномасштабне вторгнення на вашу
думку після цих усіх порушень
міжнародного права грубих порушень чи
має міжнародне право якесь вагу для цієї
держави для Російської Федерації
Російської Федерації міжнародне право не
має жодної ваги як
відомий прислів є про те що будь-яка
угода з ними не вартує папером на якій
вона вона написана ми пересвідчуємося в
цьому кожен день ви і так так само як і
ми бачимо чого вартує будь-яка угода
наприклад по зерну коли в день її
підписання чи на наступний день на
одещину полетіли ракети Там приблизно в
локацію Порту
вони свідомо ігнорують будь-які
міжнародні конвенції вони свідомо
ігнорують рішення міжнародних судових
інституцій Але тим не менш от Саме так
таким механізмом юридичної оцінки
можливості притягнення до
відповідальності Путіна через створення
трибуналу доведення вини у злочині
агресії Я думаю що це дуже ефективна
історія для того щоб
окремі особи і на майбутнє в історії
розуміли що таке робити не варто щоб
вони будуть ізольовані від всього світу
рази назавжди як протягти до
відповідальності не лише Путіна і
військово-політичне керівництво а і всіх
що робиться завдання цим завданням
займається національною компетентні
слідчі органи і
органи прокуратури
доведення вини в конкретних воєнних
злочинах вчиненні вчинених
військовослужбовцями армії Росії на
території України
ці злочини і вина в цих злочинів бути То
вводитися і в українських судах і окремо
цим питанням займається міжнародна
кримінальний суд Який так само офіс
прокурора МКС він досліджує питання
воєнних злочинів
комунікація з цим офісом прокурорів МКС
відбувається щоденна Я дуже сподіваюся
на те що нове очільник Генеральної
прокуратури зможе інтенсифікувати цю
комунікацію через те щоб Ну я знаю точно
що МКС хоче вже отримати доступ до
конкретних військових армій РФ які
готові давати свідчення проти Росії
ще один напрямок - це компенсація
збитків яких Україна зазнала внаслідок
агресії їх планується покрити за рахунок
заморожених активів Росії за кордоном
Наскільки я розумію якщо неправильно
поправте за про яку суму йдеться І коли
це може статися я думаю що такої сталої
Суми у вигляді такої цифри сталої
Константин не існує взагалі тому що Суми
активів і активів і суми коштів вони
заморожуються якщо не щодня то там
доволі часто ми маємо зрозуміти з вами
Що є умовно два типи коштів є кошти
суверені це кошти державні кошти Росії
які розміщені в іноземних юрисдикціях і
є кошти фізичних і юридичних осіб які
заблоковані заморожені в цих самих
йорзикціях ось особи які надають
підтримку режиму Путіна
будучи реалістом в цьому питанні можу
сказати про те що набагато важче важче
йде робота з
обговорення моделі компенсації внаслідок
отримання доступу саме до суверенних
коштів Росії
хто блокує цей доступ чому це часто воно
ви знаєте воно явно не блокується ну
питання воно більше політичне тому що
Російська Федерація яка розміщувала
суверенні кошти своєї країни наприклад в
юрисдикції Сполучених Штатів Америки
Франції Німеччини вони це розміщували
під гарантії цих країн
тому я сподіваюся що найближчим часом це
питання буде винесене на засідання ООН
Ми сподіваємося отримаємо резолюцію яка
трішки пожвавить
домовленості з окремими країнами про
доступ до цих ресурсів ми маємо
усвідомити з вами що взагалі Ми і в
цьому питанні і в питаннях компенсації
ми фактично робимо світовий прецедент
такого в історії не було Тому що ми
хочемо отримати доступ до коштів які в
подальшому спрямовуються на компенсацію
без згоди країни-агресора
Тобто це не класичні репарації не
класичні контрибуції це доступ до коштів
внаслідок розв'язання неоголошеної війни
злочину агресії проти іншої країни
ви вже згадали про нового очільника
офісу генпрокурора що було не так із
попередньою очільницею із розслідуванням
воєнних злочинів за її каденції І що
зміниться Тепер я напевно не хотів би
давати оцінку вже
екс-генпрокурором тому що це напевно вже
не трішки етично вже людина пішла з
посади парламент це рішення підтримав
президент рішення прийняв
чого ми очікуємо від нового Генерального
прокурора ми очікуємо як я вже згадав
інтенсифікацію взаємовідносин з
Міжнародним кримінальним судом саме в
частині не тільки обміну інформацією про
воєнні злочини Ми хочемо щоб воєнні
злочинці армії РФ вже почали з'являтися
в міжнародному криміному суді для
доведення їхньої вини це дуже важливо
Ми просили би нового Генерального
прокурора про те що він має переглянути
концепцію або відношення ставлення до
координації між органами досудового
розслідування тому що в питаннях
документування воєнних злочинів в
Україні займається всі органи досудового
розслідування буквально всі і всі
допомагають в цьому Я думаю що ми хочемо
скажімо більш такі відчутний знаєте риб
ривок в бік практичного доведення вини
Ми бачили вже процес над росіянином
шишимаріним
ви маєте на увазі Ось такі процеси
Більше таких процесів щоб ну це якраз
таки практично доведення вони є різні
різні Скажімо так процесуальні моменти
які у нас при старій команді офіса
генпрокурора викликали певну
занепокоєність От наприклад була
зроблена заява про те що в Україні
розслідується там 15-16-20 тисяч
злочинів от ми такі речі сприймали не
більше як статистику Чому Тому що для
розслідування такої кількості злочинів
ми з вами маємо розуміти потрібно де
взяти людей де взяти відповідну
кількість слідчих прокурорів теж в
кожному злочині є своя група прокурорів
да тому для того щоб
перейти від умовно там піару і
статистиків практично площину доведення
вини у конкретних кримінальних
провадженнях треба замислитися на тим чи
не уніфікувати ці провадження в
заробити їх більш щільними кількості Да
і
прокурори мають
спрямовувати
рух досудового розслідування для того
щоб розуміти і суспільство це доводити
Що там в очікуванні перспективі
конкретні особи представник Перед судом
зараз поки три
ває судову реформу зараз в часи війни як
вона буде продовжуватися
судова реформа такі відчутний поштовх до
реалізації судової реформи був зроблений
Минулого року коли парламент прийняв
низку законопроектів що передбачає
фактично оновлення складу Вищої ради
правосуддя започаткування механізму
перевірки на доброчесність кандидатів до
Вищої ради правосуддя ця перевірка Якраз
сьогодні триває В мене є очікування і
сподівання що ми там в жовтні цього року
можна зможемо наблизитися до запуску
оновленого складу Вищої ради правосуддя
і вище кваліфікаційної комісії судді але
це не все ми дійсно зараз задумуємося
над тим яким буде наступний етап судової
реформи у нас є напрацювання Ми хочемо
все ж таки щоб в Україні запрацював суд
права мова йде про верховний суд щоб у
нас відбувалася дійсно
формування стало єдиної судової практики
це надзвичайно важливо для судів нижчих
інстанцій Верховному судові достатньо
сформувати раз і на на якісь довгі
проміжок часу правову позицію з
розв'язання того чи іншого спорту для
того щоб ця позиція вона прижилася у
суспільстві і люди які звертатимуться до
судів нижчих інстанцій вони змогли
принаймні ще до звернення оцінити свою
перспективу А в нас буває часто що
окремі колеги в суді в касаційному з
абсолютно ідентичних спірних правил
відносин протягом там одного-двох днів
можуть виносити рішення які абсолютно
протирічать одне одному це велика біда
соцмережах зараз гуляють такі документи
нібито злив нібито документів з
посольства США не знаю Чи чули ви про
них чи ні там таке досьє на працівників
офісу президента і там на вас також є
досьє таке невелике в ньому зазначено Що
серед усьо з іншого що ви нібито
відповідальні за зрив судової реформи що
ви скажете на це і Який ваш внесок у
судову реформу так як я вже сказав в
2021 році влітку парламент проголосував
і президент підписав всі ключові
законопроекти
які
народилися саме внаслідок домовленостей
і переговорів з нашими міжнародними
партнерами
наші міжнародні партнери наполягали на
тому аби ми передбачили запровадження в
Україні механізму перевірки на
доброчесність кандидатів до Вищої ради
правосуддя
і
створення
допоміжного органу етичної Ради за
участю наших міжнародних партнерів ми
все це зробили все це виконали це було і
домовленостями з Міжнародним валютним
фондом із Європейським Союзом тому
що я можу зірвати мені трішки
незрозуміло ми всі домовленості виконали
повністю тоді ще важливо питання сап Ось
з'явився також очільник сад новий
Олександр Клименко
довгоочікуване таке призначення і він
серед іншого зробив таке висловлювання
що він би раніше Ще не робив це
висловлювання що він би по-іншому
розслідував справу Олега татарова Якби
він був на посаді Того часу коли ця
справа ще розслідувалась зараз вона
зайшла в глухий кут термін не всі
закінчилися до суду вона так і не дійшла
на вашу думку чи варто було би цю справу
реанімувати і і якби її варто було
розслідувати це питання трішки
провокаційне тому що все ж таки Олег
Татаров працює поки що в офісі
президента і формально з формальної
точки зору Я є його колегою тому я не
можу я буду ухилятися від відповіді на
це на це питання У громадськості просто
дуже багато питань є саме тим Хай
займається новий очільник
спеціалізованої антикорупційної
прокуратури Нехай вони процесуально
вирішують що що робити з цим питанням Я
не є прокурором Я не є слідчим тому я
думаю що ми це питання пропустимо зараз
просто дуже багато закидів якраз таки
Ось на працівників офісу президента
тонна Андрія Єрмака його часто
демонізують на того ж Олега татарова ось
це досьє яке гуляє соцмережами на вас Як
ви думаєте чому так багато негативу йде
на бік офісу президента це політика вона
була є і нікуди не дінеться тому що
Ну давайте розбиратися з 2019 року
Україна провела
маленьких середніх і великих реформ в
різних секторах економіки стільки
скільки не проводилося за всі 30 років
коли політичні опоненти бачать рейтинг
довіри до влади Звісно що це не не дає
оцього маневру для їхнього політичного
зросту Ви б не пояснили що ситуацію з
позбавленням громадянства Геннадія
Корбана Ви колись з ним працювали дійсно
це був одним з моїх клієнтів буквально
нещодавно давав інтерв'ю одному виденю і
так само задавали Це питання Я не Входжу
На жаль чи на щастя до комісії з питань
громадянства Я переконаний що для цього
рішення мали передувати якась інформація
або матеріали які були ініційовані на
розгляді цієї комісії комісія прийняла
рішення мені навіть невідомо чи воно
взагалі існує Ну я його не бачив ні
фізично Ніяк Так само як і про
громадянство Вадима Рабінович Ігоря
Коломойського
завжди одним документом той що був
опублікований в ЗМІ те що я прочитав в
соціальних мережах там був один документ
один указ
тому мова йде про про одну бумагу про
один папер просто от якраз Новое время
якщо не помиляюся назвали у вас
архітектором цього рішення
це повно маячня повна маячня тому що
комісія з питаннях громадянства комісії
з питань помилування вона ніяким чином
не зав'язана на мене жодним чином
абсолютно ну дивіться я зможу впевнено
щось коментувати коли я дійсно
переконаюся що ці укази існують Я
взагалі зараз ще знаходжуся в сумніві
тому що для того щоб ну щось
обговорювати мені треба це побачити я їх
не бачив
ще що дозволите трохи особисте питання
ось ви згадали що Ви колись захищали
Геннадія Корбана також Ви колись
захищали Олену Лукаш Міністр юстиції
часів Віктора Януковича Олександра
Єфремова Партія регіонів Ігоря гучко
редактора страна ua ви не шкодуєте про
цей етап у своєї кар'єри і це Ну ми
можемо багато говорити про те що
адвокати не можна ототожнювати з
клієнтом але
я можу сказати що вот з іншою вже
Скажімо так
подивившись на політику з іншого місця
сидіння да Багато речей я би дійсно би
переглянув
Я ніколи не задавався питаннями коли був
в адвокатом чи
наскільки провалює для мене політичне
забарвлення клієнту коли для адвоката це
суто заробіток то зараз через призму
багатьох речей що відбувається в країні
в тому числі війни
Я думаю що я би по-іншому би ставився до
до певного кола своїх своїх клієнтів
але в ЗМІ дуже часто згадують тільки цих
клієнтів вони не згадують інших вони не
згадують того що я був представником
Дмитра Яроша просто цікаво як ви
поєднували це ви були на майдані і
водночас через наголошую на тому що для
адвоката це робота це професійна
діяльність не більше не менше
просто вже зараз через призму тих подій
що відбувається в країні Ну дійсно я б
напевно вже
якщо повернувся в практичну адвокатуру
то клієнтів які своєю риторикою фактично
підтримували
розгортання ворожої пропаганди в країні
я би напевно би не взяв захист
об'єктивно не взяв
ще була історія з Романом ратушним
активістом який захищав протестів яр
також багато ЗМІ про це писали і сам
Ратушний не раз заявляв про те що і
Геннадій Корбан і ви його тодішній
представник вчинили на нього нібито тиск
публікувалися аудіозаписи якраз у справі
про та свого яру забудови протасового
яру зараз є петиція про присвоєння
роману ратушному Звання Героя України
посмертно тому що він загинув на фронті
На жаль ви підтримуєте цю петицію так
особисто звісно підтримую Я вважаю його
взірцем молоді які ну дивіться в мене
коли я прочитав новину про те що загинув
Роман Ну чесно скажу мені було дуже-дуже
боляче за цю історію
тобто я хотів би перегорнути би те що
було в нас
раніше тому що я досі вважаю що це було
просто непорозуміння
і
Роман настільки завтято займався
протасовим яром щоб багато судових
рішень які були вже після того інциденту
вже і суспільства всі інші могли б
побачити що жодної спроб спроби тиску на
суд не існувало
протестів Яр відстоєний
Я знаю що Київська Влада прийняла
рішення про те що там буде знаходиться
парк чи склер імені Романа
моє особисте ставлення Дійсно я я
підтримував
Ну і на сам кінець зараз багато що
говорять про те як Україна зміниться
після війни про те що буде після
перемоги на вашу думку як війна змінить
Україну чи зробить суди чеснішими
суспільство
вимогливішим владу прозорішою з якою ви
бачите далі Україну Я вважаю що війна в
принципі це не тільки трагедія але
можливість України очиститися від від
багатьох чортів від усюди і судової
гілки влади від усюди Але ж вони самі Та
просто не підуть може ми ж маємо
розуміти це і нам не на користь грає
дуже коротка пам'ять у людей ми будемо
після перемоги ми будемо очевидно дуже
захоплені цим фактом фактом Перемоги але
не треба забувати що багато
корисних і не корисних ідіотів зрадників
вони нікуди не поділися вони рано чи
пізно піднімуть голову
і з цього треба теж робити висновок
об'єктивно Андрій Олександрович Дякую за
цю розмову